all right she should be here any minute
her name is alicia
switch with me that's your good side i
have a bad side oh damn you didn't know
all right can we just focus on finding
the veil really it's not a big deal i'm
sure it's in her car
oh there she is do you mind if i slyly
mention you're single
do not do that you won't even notice hey
you needed to see me again rose is
single what
ignore him we left a dry cleaning bag in
your back seat oh uh i didn't see
anything but you could take a look
the veil's not here rosa we're so
screwed hold on
don't freak out
[Music]
rosa what the hell are you doing what
you were the one that said that was
before the bear went missing when life
was breezy
[Applause]
this place is outstanding great call
leslie knope
look even ben's dancing
[Music]
hey there how's it going great
thanks can i buy you a drink oh
i'm very flattered but this is my
stunningly gorgeous day in perkins
oh hi hi sorry
oh no problem in fact let me buy all of
you a drink
for being so welcoming today on the
house leslie
oh thank you i'm sort of a
gay hero last year i married two
penguins at the zoo and it turned out
they were both gay
the pawnee zoo recently purchased two
south african black-footed penguins
tux and flipper and as part of our zoo
promotion
we are going to give them a marriage
ceremony
because they mate for life tux
do you take flipper to be your lawfully
wedded wife
i do i do by the power vested in me
from the department of parks and
recreation i now pronounce you
husband and wife
oh
[Music]
okay well at least you're married i'll
say making babies
well not those two those are both boy
penguins
i'm sorry tux and flipper are both boys
so you should have pronounced them
husband and husband technically
that's awesome
still i couldn't have asked for better
weather penguin wedding
that's cute it was so cute we don't seem
to have any training videos about
not discussing abortion at work because
we just thought it was
so obvious but you guys managed to
surprise us
so good job whoa don't lecture us on
being responsible when we all know what
you did to sandra
sandra who's sandra who's sandra
just the woman who's pregnant with your
biracial child
in his defense sandra is extremely
forgettable remember we left her at dave
and buster's on her birthday
yeah yeah i'm not pregnant
oh what god am i too late i'm very
confused wait
so you didn't knock her up no i'm gay
what oh
huh oh yeah right you're gay and i'm
lorenzo
lamas well i am i'm gay
but you're so blah well wait then who's
dating sandra
i made it up i haven't been dating
anyone i mean
nothing here pops at all why would you
make something like that up
because she's a maniac at first it was a
misunderstanding
and then i just started lacking the
attention for the first time in my life
i was a star i'm the one who's been
dating jeff
okay the whole time me me me me um we
were
keeping that between us i just don't get
it
if you can be gay that means anyone can
be gay
i'm captain raymond holt welcome
marriage is a contract
but it's so much more than that marriage
is love
it's commitment it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger it's reconciliation
it's everything it's like oatmeal
it sustains you
darlene do you take lynne to be your
lawfully wedded husband
i do lin do you take darlene to be your
lawfully wedded wife
i do i now pronounce you husband and
wife you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i gotta hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony
it wasn't difficult i simply said what i
wish had been said when kevin and i got
married
oh well then i never would have heard
your hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing but all
this does make me think i might enjoy a
more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we
hold an honest-to-goodness wedding
nothing too elaborate
we're not the kardashian west's after
all they are a musician
and a celebrity personality who recently
wedded yes yes i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
[Laughter]
you guys are fun
thank you
it's gorgeous angela yeah i actually
know about nice rings and it is gorgeous
it's a little flashy i mean what am i
naomi judd
tell us the freaking story yeah tell us
a story
okay he took me to the replica of
monet's japanese bridge
and then he put this flower behind my
ear which normally i would hate because
it's so civil rightsy
then he got down on one knee and he said
will you be
a senator's wife oh
he talked about himself in the third
person yes pam
not everyone is as informal as you and
jim oh
hey pam dude whatever want to marry me
it's not accurate then i saw flashes
reporters were there
they always find us and everyone was
crying
even his aid angela's engaged to a gay
man
as a gay man i'm horrified as a friend
of angela's
horrified as a lover of elegant weddings
i'm a little excited but overall
horrified you swear this guy's about to
meet up with his mistress
yep tuesday at five it's tonya time
wow there he goes okay now we gotta get
rid of the other deputy glass eye you're
up
ah so much drier than i would have
thought did i want it to be wet
jake right sorry it's holding an eyeball
in my hand no big deal here we go
yeah what the hell
must have gotten too hot sheriff i'm
gonna go get a mop
great now we stage a fight when the
sheriff comes in to bring it up we take
him down
why isn't he coming in i don't know
maybe he's not buying it hit me harder
just go with me on this all right
i can't stay mad at you huh
oh no no is it working break it off
not my jail no no bro
stop it what are you doing it's 2016
man this is on you okay quick update on
the warren street break in security
cameras caught a picture of the suspect
and guess what
that's right we got a hot purple alert
that's a handsome man i'd like to bring
that guy to justice
we all would but unfortunately police
cornered him and he shot himself in the
face
all right thank you for that shockingly
dark update anything else
uh yes something i'd like to say a
pretty private person so this is kind of
hard for me but
here we go i'm bisexual
all right i will now field one minute
and zero seconds of questions pertaining
to this go
amy how long have you known since
seventh grade i was watching saved by
the bell and i thought
zack morris is hot and then i thought at
least a turtle
also hot the fact that the words kelly
and kapowski didn't just come out of
your mouth is lunacy what made you
decide to tell us now
charles found out on the road trip and i
was positive he was not gonna be able to
keep the secret for much longer
bye rosa i mean not bye but bye
i mean see ya i mean have fun only
having sex with men just banging dudes
left and right
i just stopped saying bye all together
so are you seeing anyone now yeah her
name's tiffany are you lying about her
name so we won't look her up yes i am
next
do you know anne hage i do oh i must say
this is going considerably better than
when i came out to my colleagues
they were not as the kids say awake do
you mean woke i did mean woke but it's
grammatically incoherent okay we have
time for one more question oh
no absolutely not we're done smart
it was not tasteful
you